bienvenue dans la fri connect chef de
l'état en afrique pour ce poste certains
semblent avoir signé un contrat à durée
indéterminée président à vie en perdre
la vie ou forcés de quitter le pouvoir à
la faveur d'un coup d'état a parmi les
records de longévité on peut citer
muamar kadhafi 40 ans à deux pouvoirs en
libye 33 ans pour félix houphouët boigny
en côte d'ivoire 37 ans de pouvoir
cumuler comme premier ministre et
président pour robert mugabe au zimbabwe
tous ces anciens dirigeants ne sont plus
ce monde paul biya au cameroun lui est
toujours là au pouvoir depuis trente
sept ans alors fait longévité des
présidents africains comment l'expliquer
on en parle avec notre invité pascal
affi n'guessan ex premier ministre
opposants et leader du front populaire
ivoirien un parti fondé au départ par
laurent gbagbo bonjour pascal affi
n'guessan et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans la fri connect un jour
que vous inspire cette notion de
président à vie c'est une notion d'une
autre époque
une époque où la pensée unique du parti
unique mais c'est une époque révolue et
à l'heure actuelle
dans tous les pays d'afrique un
mouvement de démocratisation est en
cours c'est vrai que les fortunes sont
diverses mais c'est un processus est
irréversible et il est tout à fait
évident que
dans les années à venir nous
n'entendrons plus parler de ce type de
régions où nous aurons partout en
afrique a cédé le principe démocratique
où l'alternance démocratique la
stabilité politique et donc
autant il ya eu en cours le parti unique
autant il aura un temps pour les régimes
des dictatures
alors depuis l'accession à
l'indépendance justement l'alternance
politique est inexistant dans de
nombreux pays du continent si bien que
des générations d'africains n'ont connu
qu'un seul président et la liste des
dirigeants qui se maintiennent au
pouvoir et longues ou tente de se
maintenir au pouvoir on voit cela avec
aléas de cazaux
qu'il soit sorti des urnes ou de leur
armée nationale bon nombre de dirigeants
africains accumule les tours de
passe-passe et modifie la constitution
pour briguer un énième mandat
les paul biya teodoro obiang et autres
yuweri museveni semble encore plus
indéboulonnable que la statue d'un
christophe colomb à baltimore face à une
communauté internationale qui ne réagit
pas tour d'horizon des records de
longévité au pouvoir sur le continent
la médaille d'or revient sans conteste à
teodoro obiang nguema et ses 42 ans à la
tête de la guinée équatoriale plus
anciens présidents en exercice au monde
obiang arrive au pouvoir en 79 depuis
teodoro n'a plus jamais quitté le trône
la faute à un électorat anormalement
homogène obiang a toujours obtenu plus
de 90% des votes et histoire d'assurer
la transition son vice président n'est
autre que son propre fils
direction la république du congo denis
sassou nguesso 77 ans et quatre mandats
au compteur marquée par l'emprisonnement
de ses opposants réélu en mars dernier
sassou nguesso prête serment je jure
solennellement
de respecter
et de faire respecter
la constitution et place illico son fils
au ministère de la coopération
internationale
de quoi rendre jaloux son voisin
camerounais avec ses 88 ans dont 38 à la
tête de l'état paul biya est qualifié
d'autoritaire en 2018 après une
présidentielle remportée sans surprise
son principal opposant maurice kamto est
emprisonné sans procès officiellement
pour destruction de biens publics
officieusement pour contestation du
pouvoir en place un véritable palmarès
auquel s'ajoutent yoweri musevini qui
règne sur l'eau ganda depuis 1986 la
démocrature rwandaise de paul kagamé
adoubé pour les progrès attribuée au
pays mais critiqué pour le muselage de
la liberté d'expression dont il fait
usage sans oublier la récente élection
d'alassane ouattara en côte d'ivoire
porté par les urnes avec +2 83% des voix
alors est il temps pour la communauté
internationale d'arrêter de fermer les
yeux sur la corruption qui sévit en
afrique comment stabiliser les
institutions sans risque et l'ingérence
et par où doit commencer la quête de
démocratie sur le continent
pascal affi n'guessan quelles sont les
raisons qui poussent les chefs d'état à
se maintenir au pouvoir
universel sec le voit courante et le
pouvoir absolu corrompt absolument
il faut donc adressé des baillets aura
empêché que des pouvoirs l'instinct ce
talent de façon absolue dans un pays et
ses bas rien ne peut venir que de la
société des leaders politiques des
organisations politiques et c'est à ce
niveau dont il faut axer ses efforts en
termes de formation des élites
politiques africaines mais aussi en
termes de conscientisation des masses
des populations à travers l'éducation à
travers la prise de conscience des uns
les
objectifs des populations de manière à
ce que la conscience nationale dévolue
que les citoyens africains sorte de
conscience ethnique de l'inconscience
théologique
adhérer pour s'élever à une conscience
objective à une conscience politique
idéologique pour comprendre qu'en
définitive leur destin n'est pas lié au
fait que un des leurs et qu'ils soient
de leur ethnie leur religion et à la
tête de l'état mais que l'esclave est la
compétition politique à travers la
compétition à deux projets politiques
entre idées politiques pour que le choix
porté sur dix qui propose le programme
pertinent pour résoudre les problèmes du
pays que ce à travers la mesure des
problèmes de pauvreté qui
gangrènent nos sociétés africaines et
pascal affi n'guessan cette persistance
des chefs d'état africains vouloir ce
martyr pouvoir est ce que vous pensez
que c'est lié à un goût du pouvoir ou
bien c'est pour échapper
à la justice pour éviter d'avoir à
rendre des comptes une fois que le
mandat est terminé rendre des comptes
devant la justice pour des faits de
corruption des crimes de guerre même nom
mais c'est une tendance naturelle de
l'homme de vouloir toujours avoir du
pouvoir et c'est seulement un but tout
pouvoir et
opposition politique qui peut
contraindre ceux qui sont au pouvoir a
modéré le pouvoir et un moment donné a
accepté de libérer le pouvoir
donc c'est une tendance naturelle des
hommes et six en europe le leader
politique ne s'engage pas dans ces gens
dans des situations c'est facile et une
société civile ni un peuple éduqué tu
n'es pas prêt à accepter qu'un chef
d'état super mais nous voulons voir
s'éterniser au pouvoir donc en afrique
ce n'est pas seulement parce que c'est
chez fonds décès de tendance cette
volonté de rester mais c'est parce qu'en
face il n'y a pas de contre-pouvoirs
suffisamment fort pour les contraindre à
libérer les voies à modérer le pouvoir
est dans ce sens est contre voilà qu'il
faut développer et le premier contre le
pouvoir c'est le peuple c'est la
conscience politique peu la petite
comprend que le pouvoir absolu sécrète
nécessairement la mauvaise gouvernance
et qu'il faut qu'il le refuse
qu'un chef d'état ce dernier au pouvoir
qu'il s'engage à nouveau parmi les
moyens de se maintenir au pouvoir ya le
tripatouillage constitutionnel
on se souvient du cas ivoirien avec le
prêt dix ans le président alassane
ouattara qui a soulevé une forte
contestation populaire avec des
violences mais le cas le plus flagrant
le cas d'école c'est quand même celui du
burundi avec pierre couronne za qui
avait modifié la constitution en 2018
pour se maintenir au pouvoir jusqu'en
2034 au terme de trois mandats pascal
affi n'guessan qu'est ce qui rend
possible ces révisions
constitutionnelles est ce que laissait
la faiblesse des institutions africaines
mais bien sûr c'est la faiblesse des
institutions mais la faiblesse des
expulsions et liées à la faiblesse de la
société civile du processus de mourir je
dirais de l'esprit démocratique dans le
pays tant que
les citoyens ne se sent pas à pau le
pouvoir et c'est à dire que la
souveraineté du peuple n'est pas
suffisamment
consolidée parce que les citoyens sont
conscients que c'est eux c'est à lui
qu'appartient le pouvoir est-il dévolu à
un moment donné à un homme d'honneur et
que si celui ci
contre à vie leurs ambitions ils sont
fondés à 9 huard acide tant qu'il n'aura
pas cette prise de conscience peut pas
éviter les tripatouillages donc mais ce
qu'il faut noter c'est que même dans
tous les pays où ces chefs d'état ses
livres à cette voiture
qui s'organise qui se manifestent ça
veut dire qu'il ya une prise de
conscience mais cette prise de
conscience n'a pas encore atteint un
niveau de maturité tel de bloquer
d'empêcher que cette pâturages la venue
en côte d'ivoire c'est ce qui s'est
passé en 2000 grain il ya une forte
résistance au troisième mandat une fois
de résistance à la commission
indépendante des zones et au pouvoir
évidemment elle a lu des limites mais
c'est qu'ils sont au pouvoir ont bien
compris que qui ne peuvent pas l une est
mans tentait de tripatouiller la
constitution ils trouveront toujours en
face d'eux une oppose une opposition une
opinion publique qui va refuser et je
pense que c'est en tirant les leçons de
ce genre de situation que
progressivement les leaders politiques
ont modéré leurs ambitions et respecter
la constitution parce qu'ils ont pris
une pente
l'opposition autre moyen de se maintenir
au pouvoir c'est l'instrumentalisation
des élections que l'on présente comme un
gage de démocratie pourquoi
l'organisation d'élections transparentes
reste toujours un défi sur le continent
africain mais
le continent africain et dans leur
démocratisation nous n'avons pas encore
des institutions démocratiques nous
n'avons pas encore un peu plus
suffisamment acquis au au principe à la
culture démocratique
il ya encore beaucoup de pays africains
une forte proportion de la population
qui attachés à la question ethnique est
qui qui donc préfère soutenir des
régimes parce que ce régime est dirigée
par un des nôtres unique ou internautes
au plan religieux donc qui sont parmi
eux qui ne sont pas encore attise à la
démocratie et donc c'est donc cette
disons limite à l'adhésion avant
rapidement de la démocratie qui fait que
les versions parfois google ce régime là
tout dans l'opinion d'un support des
soutiens en faveur de leur volonté de se
pérenniser au pouvoir mais parce que si
à travers le processus démocratique
de plus en plus de citoyens adhèrent au
principe que ce n'est pas parce que elle
est maintenant que tous nos problèmes
seront réglés qu'il faut au contraire
que nous nous débarrassions de cette
vision des choses que nous cherchons pas
placée en notre société un dernier un
citoyen qui a une expérience politique a
une histoire avec le peuple et qui a un
projet politique et libérateur un projet
politique pour résoudre les problèmes
d'emploi des jeunes le besoin
d'éducation de santé de développement
local que c'est plutôt vers cela qu'il
faut tendre vers la recherche d'un
leader et qui peut résoudre nos
problèmes il faut tendre et non vers la
région a précisé qu'il ya ici deux
régions lorsque ce processus là cette
prise de conscience aura mûri il est
évident que aucun chef d'état ne pourra
envisager de bâtir des élections passées
ne sera pas suivi
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
vous êtes vous même un opposant en côte
d'ivoire l'un des principaux opposants
côte d'ivoire ce que vous avez
l'impression que vous vous jouer
suffisamment votre rôle à nous et nous
jouons dans le contexte qui est le nôtre
et comme vous me l'avez dit en 2020 face
à la volonté du chef de l'état de faire
un troisième mandat en violation de la
constitution et d'organiser les
élections avait une commission qui
n'était pas indépendante nous avons
assumé notre responsabilité de dire
engagé dans la lys en civil avec le
résultat que vous connaissez et c'est
vrai que nous n'avons pas pu empêcher
ces élections et c'est que vaille au
pouvoir mais dans tous les cas il en
entrevue il nous a vécu et je suis
persuadé que qui a motivé le lui sont
que chacun d'entre eux en a tiré la
leçon est que l'espagnol de deux
éleveurs je ne suis pas sûr que le cas
du sur de petits c'est à dire que en
2025 ne soit
on encore de se présenter parce qu'il
sait combien de fois cela a été pour
nous de lespignan de bellevue pascal
affi n'guessan on va marquer une courte
pause et poursuivre dans un instant
restez avec nous sur afrique honnête
retour dans l'âtre iconnect on se
reconnecte avec notre invité pascal affi
n'guessan opposant ivoirien pascal affi
n'guessan on évoque la longévité des
présidents africains on parlait
justement du rôle de l'opposition
ces pouvoirs d'africains qui profitent
aussi des divisions des luttes
intestines au sein des oppositions
africaines finalement on se rend bien
compte que cela les renforce évidemment
c'est sont effectivement des situations
qu'il n'atteindrait pas le processus de
démocratisation d'appli les
contradictions à l'intérieur de
l'opposition
l'absence de conscience
démocratique de certains élites
politiques c'est ce sont des réalités ce
sont des limites et la solution se
trouve dans la formation il est évident
que ces situations sont vécues parce que
c'est un parti politique se constitue
sans aucune base idéologique sans aucune
base politique parfois uniquement parce
que c'est une personne en vie date c'est
de pouvoir mais sûrement pas disant que
même
les dissensions ethniques et donc c'est
tout cela aussi qu'il contribue à
affaiblir le président démocratique en
afrique et donc pour que le grossiste
actionnaires il faut des politiques de
l'opposition 102 soient de vrais partis
politiques qui ont un programme de
gouvernement qui savent clairement que
ses ambitions pour leur pays et qui sont
capables dans ce cadre là de pouvoir
conclu des alliances politiques et
d'autres formations de l'opposition de
manière à constituer une offre proche du
positionnement crédible mais pour
mobiliser leur population
la fondation ce que l'on observe c'est
que les oppositions utilise aussi des
méthodes en dehors du cadre
institutionnel c'était le cas en côte
d'ivoire lorsque vous et vos confrères
de l'opposition vous aviez former un
gouvernement de transition
un acte qui a été perçu comme à une
sédition par le pouvoir ivoirien sait
franchir un peu ligne rouge c'est
vraiment nécessaire est ce que c'est
vraiment crédible non et a pas eu de
formation du gouvernement de transition
il ya eu l'idée d'appeler à la formation
d'un gouvernement de transition et en
données de comptes ce politique auquel
nous étions confrontés pour le chef
d'état était arrivé en fin de mandat et
où l'élection présidentielle s'est passé
dans les conditions antidémocratiques
nous avons pris acte de ce que le mandat
du président terminée et les élections
n'hésitant pas organisé conformément à
la loi par conforme à la constitution il
y avait un vite et que donc à la classe
politique toutes les forces vives du est
rassemblée dans le cadre de ce cnt dont
c'était un appel à la à la concertation
nationale en vue de définir les règles
de gestion du pays et d'organisations
d'organisation d'élections justes et
transparentes
le conseil national de transition
après c'est spécial
évidemment en afrique compte tenu du
faible esthétique ne pouvons pas faire
l'économie de ces régions des situations
parce que il est
manifestement les systèmes en place et
il ne peut plus avancer il ne peut pas
s'inscrire dans une logique démocratique
franchement il faut passer par une phase
de transition et les caennais font leur
serve aux autres outre le rôle de
l'opposition celui de l'armée s'invite
aussi dans un jeu trouble pour détrôner
les élans monarchique des armes est
capable de mener des coups de force pour
débarrasser les sociétés civiles de
président à vie de pouvoir on va écouter
l'analyse d'oswald pas de nous à ce
propos politologue béninois et directeur
du programme à l'école nationale des
arts messiaen
l'armée ne peut pas être considérée
comme garant de la démocratie la
démocratie et son c'est être garantis
par les institutions l'armée en réalité
n'est pas nécessairement le garant de la
démocratie mais le garant de
l'indépendance nationale est le garant
de la souveraineté et a pour mission
donc de protéger le territoire protéger
la population
alors il se fait que bien entendu compte
tenu de ses spécificités
elle peut être
amené à intervenir elle a été souvent
amenés à intervenir en afrique en tout
cas dans le champ politique et je pense
qu'il ne faut pas considérer que cela
relève de ses prérogatives de cette voie
qu'il faut dix ont banalisé ces
interventions sur la scène même si dans
certaines circonstances bien entendu
elles se justifient elles peuvent se
justifier elle pulse expliqué mais bien
entendu il faut veiller à
ce que les sections ne devienne la règle
ce que démontre la fréquence des coups
d'état notamment ces dernières années en
afrique de l'ouest
particulièrement la demande de malaise
de malaise politique de malaise social
cela démontre un peu des limites de la
démocratie si on veut s'arrêter à la
compréhension disons de la d7 démocratie
quelque peu confisquées dans les régimes
présidentiels quand nous avons eu qui se
sont très largement présidentialiser au
les chefs d'état ont eu à se considérer
à être considéré comme étant finalement
des monarques républicains donc celle-ci
de tous ces malaises la key qui se
cristallise un peu dans ses coups d'état
que nous avons maintenant à répétition
en afrique de l'ouest mais aussi
ailleurs alors ce qu'il faut ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que le l'intervention
des armées dans le dans le jeu politique
vient quelque peu
grand place et bien quelqu'un puisse se
substituer aux institutions de contre
pouvoirs qui sont censés réguler le jeu
politique qui ne le font pas ou qui ne
le sont pas assez bien donc en réalité
ce qu'il faut chercher à comprendre à
améliorer c'est comment cette démocratie
qui est finale en service de quelques
heures et qui peut aussi se traduit par
une sorte de confiscation du pouvoir
comment cette démocratie là se réinvente
comment elles se mêlent finalement au
service de l'intérêt général
on
va là vous pouvez retrouver
l'intégralité de cette intervention
d'oswald padonou sur notre site rt
france point tv pascal affi n'guessan
les récents coups d'état en guinée au
mali plus enseignement plus enseignement
au burkina faso et au niger ont été
accueillis favorablement par les société
civile et l'opposition si bien que l'on
parle de coup d'état démocratique quelle
est votre appréciation de cette réalité
mais comme il l'a indiqué au quai un
coût total considérées comme
démocratiques
la limite on peut considérer que le
coude étape permet de rue bat leucate
dans un contexte où le régime au pouvoir
a du mal à imposer sa volonté aux plats
à l'opposition et que la situation de
blocage et turchini succès une
intervention militaire mais dans tous
les cas comme il adore servait cette
intervention militaire
rebelle et parleurs à 0 et à travers une
transition
devrait logiquement les conditions d'une
compétition plus équilibrée qui aurait
pu permettre soin de régler les
questions de kadrige et d'utilisation
des directions des questions de
transparence du processus électoral de
manière à ce qu au bout de la transition
le projet démocratique soit mieux
articuler et permet d'organiser des
élections justes et transparentes dont
10,6 à des conditions que les militaires
ne s'éternise pas au pouvoir évidemment
celui que les forces politiques qui ont
cru et la situation par origer
l'intrusion d'un militaire doivent
rester mobilisés vigilante pour que de
la même façon qu'elles se sont opposés
au régime en place qu'elles soient
prêtes à s'opposer au régime militaire
si et tous les styles de prendre la
place du régime vaincu du marché à
l'egypte est-ce qu'il faut considérer
que l'absence de bruits de bottes et que
le cantonnement de l'armée dans les
casernes constituent de bons signes de
fonctionnement démocratique comme c'est
le cas dans votre pays
évidemment ces timbres aussi dans la
main tant que là mais steam pas le codev
politique
justifie pour intervenir et fit que les
forces politiques des jours dans une
certaine mesure la partition l'europe
que là ce n'est pas bloqué le régime en
place contrôler la situation soit qu' il
ya un contest démocratique suffisamment
livre qui permet à l'opposition de
s'exprimer et que l'armée considère que
l'eau mission dans ce contre x jouer sa
partition se donner les moyens de doper
la terrasse des forces démocratiques et
donc dans une certaine mesure je crois
que le fait que la mairesse dans sa dans
son rôle et ne reviennent pas dans les
jeux politiques est une bonne chose mais
à condition que l'on fait tout ça il
faudrait pas que cette absence de
l'armée soit d'une mainmise totale d'une
hégémonie du régime en place
c'est une véritable malle pays
dommageable pour la démocratie mars avec
les pays africains sont de jeunes
nations mais on constate quand même que
depuis les indépendances les avancées en
matière démocratique reste quand même
mitigé comment est-ce qu'on peut
l'afrique peut remporter cette bataille
pour l'alternance démocratique on
remarque par ailleurs que dans les pays
qui ont les pays qui ont instauré un
régime parlementaire on a l'impression
que ça fonctionne mais ce qu'il faut
aussi revoir les modèles de démocratie
non je pense qu'il ne faut pas voir une
appréciation
pessimistes
des régimes il a des pays où la
démocratie a fait des grands pas au
sénégal
au ghana
au kenya où on sait bien que la
démocratie a fait des grands et même
d'un pays où il y a des difficultés
les dictatures ont de plus en plus de
mal à contrer la situation qu'elles sont
contestés dont il ya un processus la
démocratie est un processus
ce n'est pas une donnée de l'immédiate
et donc il faut faire confiance au
peuple il faut faible de patience et de
persévérance
parce que tous les pays démocratiques
aujourd'hui des grandes démocraties sont
passés par là certains ont mis des six
degrés de démocratie qu'ils connaissent
à l'heure actuelle donc l'afrique est en
train de faire des expériences il faut
savoir apprécier les avancées il faut
savoir encourager les pays et puis
difficultés parce que de toute façon ce
processus est irréversible et dans près
de belp en 50 ans nous sommes piquionne
ne connaîtront plus hésitation que nous
connaissons à l'heure actuelle en
afrique
restait à ce dernier au pouvoir pascal
affi n'guessan maintenant que laurent
gbagbo vous a laissé les rênes
définitivement du front populaire
ivoirien puisque il fonde son propre
parti est ce que vous serez candidat en
2025 et est ce que si vous deviez
l'emporter vous promettez justement de
ne jamais briguer un troisième mandat
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a entendu
beaucoup d'opposants aussi faire cette
promesse et quand ils sont arrivés au
pouvoir cette promesse est devenue
caduque oui c'est vrai que ça il ya un
certain nombre de leaders quasi
charismatique nous pose qui ont déçu par
l'attitude qu'ils ont adopté une fois
mais moi je peux vous garantir que cela
nous n'est pas de ma culture
je suis un démocrate je me suis engagé
pour
contribuer à l'engrais de la démocratie
dans mon pays donc que j'essaie les
candidats à la candidature c'est le
camarade mais font confiance comme ils
ont témoigné des puits 2015 j'ai porté
les couleurs du front populaire ivoirien
légère blesure politique j'ai une
expérience politique et j'étais resté
dans le cadre constitutionnel
s'il est vrai mais pas dans la tête du
pays cinq ans et c'est le temps qu'il me
faudra
disons
nous réformer totalement l'état de quoi
qui doit résoudre les problèmes auxquels
les jeunes les femmes et les citoyens
ivoiriens sont confrontés à la fin de
ces cinq ans j'ai passé le flambeau à la
nouvelle innovation que nous sommes en
train de préparer d'ailleurs ainsi
concept du front populaire donc un seul
mandat on retient satin promesses
affichées merci beaucoup à vous pascal
affi n'guessan d'avoir participé à notre
émission afrique honnête
et retrouver la fri connecte sur nos
réseaux sociaux et notre site arte
france point tv merci de votre attention
merci aux équipes du mag pour la
préparation de cette émission aux
équipes techniques aussi
bientôt dans un trait connecte sur rt
france
[Musique]